more shelters are to come for displaced
people in North kevu Province are under
construction to ease a crowded area near
the provincial capital Goma
most of these people have fled from
fighting between the armed group M23 and
the national Army
nearly 1 million Congolese here run away
from their homes during the last year
we fled from my Village six months ago
there was too much fighting people were
dying so he came to this Camp life is
very hard we don't have basic
necessities
the United Nations says the humanitarian
crisis in Democratic Republic of Congo
is one of the most neglected in the
world thousands of people are living
rough in camps like this one they are
fleeing from conflict they say they
don't want to go back home because the
situation there is too dangerous
aren't groups in the East and other
areas have killed thousands and
displaced many more in recent years
eight agencies and the government are
also dealing with diseases and natural
disasters compounded by climate change
effects the numbers in the DRC are
staggering because of the size of the
country
the the size of the population and so it
has the highest number of food insecure
people in the world one congoles out of
four is food insecure
and it has the highest of of internally
displaced people in Africa a third
number it has over 6 million people
severely malnourished mostly children
and the five and this number has not
moved for many many years
a landslide recently Swept Away villages
in South kivu Province it was one of the
worst disasters in recent history 400
people died up to 5 000 are missing
Esther Solomon Sean's barely made it out
alive she and her husband are now trying
to get by
yeah I mean it was raining heavily we
started to take the children to safety I
have five children and another on the
way I'm building temporary shelter until
I figure out what to do
they joined more than 6 million
internally displaced Congolese who are
also trying to do what they can to
survive
Catherine soy Goma Eastern Democratic
Republic of Congo
still ahead on